[Music]
this friday marks four years since the
one october massacre 58 people died that
night in 2017 when a gunman opened fire
on the route 91 harvest festival from
mandalay bay friday morning on october
1st the sunrise remembrance ceremony
returns to the clark county government
center downtown then at the evening
friday evening names of the victims will
be read at the downtown healing garden
survivors will also gather at the site
of the shooting to form that route 91
human chain again these are things that
have been done for the last several
years
clark county has also done this once
again they've set up a memorial exhibit
in the rotunda gallery on the first
floor of the clark county government
center this display includes handmade
quilts and the art of healing murals
created by local artists if you're
interested in checking that out you can
stop by and see it through next thursday
the vegas strong 5k and one mile race
also is back this year after taking a
year off for the pandemic it is sunday
morning at floyd lamb park i have the
honor of hosting the event this year
registration for the race though is
closed but if you are taking part a
reminder pick up your packet on friday
from noon until 6 outside of the rei out
at boca park
this week eight news now will have
coverage to commemorate one october
friday morning we're going to share
stories from survivors and talk about
how the city has changed since that
tragic evening we'll also be live during
good day las vegas at the sunrise
service and you can find plenty of
stories on air and online regarding one
october at eight newsnow dot com